in Google cloud engineering support our
goal is to work smoothly with you
engineer to engineer to resolve any
issues you may encounter when using
Google cloud platform products this
video describes best practices for
filing an issue report with our support
engineers in the Google cloud support
center but it's applicable to requesting
technical assistance from any GCP
engineer this includes support cases bug
reports and issue trackers and post to
our user groups and forums like Stack
Overflow the key principle is clarity
specify the right level of technical
detail and communicate your expectations
explicitly so that we can better help
you resolve the issue the support
centers help page and earlier videos
present the mechanics of how to file
cases this will help you understand what
to include in your cases and why we will
explain the details we need and why
they're important the four critical
details to include with every case are
specific times when you experience the
issue the GCP products are using the
location and specific identifiers for
any resources relevant to your case
onset time and duration give us a way to
focus our time series monitoring on the
relevant period
please be explicit about whether the
issue is ongoing or whether it was only
observable in the past if the issue
isn't ongoing please state that and give
the endtime if you know it ISO 8601
format is good choice because it's
unambiguous and easy to sort please
always include the timezone our internal
systems tend to be in Google time which
is us specific but our agents use a
follow-the-sun model and may be in
different time zones some issues are
intermittent over a period in this case
is good to say when it's first observed
or perhaps noted time in the past when
it was not happening remark about the
frequency of observations in note one or
two specific examples when time is
specified in a relative way including a
mission of a time zone the reader must
convert into an absolute format that can
be input into time series monitoring
tools
this is error-prone and costly
especially considering that each reader
must pay the price for example sending
an email about something that happened
earlier yesterday causes the reader to
search for a header in the initial email
and start doing math in their head
phrases to avoid are things like earlier
today because it's not specific enough
or yesterday because we need to figure
out the implied date when issues take
multiple days to resolve don't use dates
like 9/8 because it's ambiguous and may
be interpreted differently another look
the case creation form includes basic
product selection which is used for
routing to a specialist in the area this
isn't specific enough to locate the
components or logs that will help
diagnose the issue be as specific as
possible about the product you're using
ideally referring to the specific api's
or console cloud Google comm URLs or
screenshots for api's you can link to
the documentation page which contains
the product name in the URL tell us
about the mechanism you're using to
initiate the request for example REST
API g-cloud tool consult
cloud.google.com or perhaps a tool like
deployment manager sometimes multiple
products are involved so try to be
specific about each one describe the
behavior observing and what you expected
then show us what you see you should be
specific about the actions you have
taken as well as the syntax of any
commands use a phrase like can't create
instance doesn't tell us whether you use
g-cloud compute the developer console UI
or called it from your own code the most
clear way to communicate this example
would be something like I ran g-cloud
compute instances create my instance
zone US central 1a and got the following
error message when including the
location region and zone are important
to us because we often roll out changes
to one region or zone at a time they are
a proxy for the version number of the
underlying software we can see if
there's a rollout underway in a given
location or map it to an internal
release ID for use in a bug report you
should include something along the lines
of I tried regions US East one or u.s.
central one in your case please make
sure to always include specific
identifiers project ID is an input to
most of our troubleshooting tools and
it's a required field when filing a case
please provide a numeric project ID not
a project name if the error is observed
in multiple projects or in one project
but not another you should include that
information in the description also
include IDs of other objects like
instance IDs bigquery job IDs or table
names IP addresses are another form of
unambiguous identifiers when specifying
a cloud platform IP tell us the context
of how it's used for example if it's
connected to a GCE instance a load
balancer a custom route or if it's an
API endpoint if you're troubleshooting a
connection issue then tell us a bit
about the IP addresses that are not part
of GC P for example if it's your home
internet a VP
point or an external monitoring system
you should always provide more specific
information than something like one of
our instances or we can't connect from
the internet because support will need
to gather more information from you
before they can begin troubleshooting
that will mean further delays in
resolving your issue for any information
you provide to support be specific and
explicit if relevant use a screenshot to
show exactly what you see for web-based
interfaces provide a har file or HTTP
archive our documentation has
instructions on how to get a har file
three major browsers when
troubleshooting networking issues attach
TCP dump output if you collect it and
also attach log snippets and example
stack traces you believe to be relevant
to the issue when you file a case
support uses the priority field for
initial routing especially when an issue
may page someone case priorities are
also described in the case creation
forum itself
use p1 for production emergencies think
of case priority in terms of the impact
your business in addition to setting the
priority field correctly it's useful to
add a sentence describing the impact in
your words for example you may consider
a problem with the diversion to be a p1
even if no end-users are directly
impacted if it's blocking a critical
security fix to avoid incorrect
assumptions it's helpful to be explicit
about why you selected p1 cases have
built in response timers which are
designed to set reasonable expectations
most of the time if you have some
specific needs please let us know when
you need an update it's good to say
something like I need a response by 5:00
p.m. because that's when my shift ends
if you notice you're affected by an
issue that's already reported on the
Status cloud.google.com
you can follow the progress in the
dashboard itself or use the me to link
in the cloud support portal to
automatically get updates for known
issues when an issue needs to be handled
around the clock customers with 24/7
support can request that the case follow
the Sun cases that follow the Sun will
be reassigned several times per day so
it's always with an active support
engineer a lower priority case will not
be managed around the clock as the
assigned support engineer will go off
shift at some point this can cause
delays if the assigned engineer is not
in your time zone you can ask us to
manage the ticket your time zone so you
can communicate more easily with the
support engineer for example you can say
please manage this case in my time zone
est this can help if you need a long
discussion with the support engineer but
may not help with the development
team is in another time zone if you need
to continue the conversation over Google
Hangouts or phone after filing a case
please provide a link or phone number if
you're requested support will try to
call when it does not interfere with
issue resolution for video bridges we
strongly prefer Google Hangouts but can
use anything that works within a Chrome
browser without requiring extensions if
you're not requesting an immediate
callback please give two or three time
slots when you're available to get
started with the scheduling thank you
for watching if you have questions
please leave them in the comments
section below and we'll try to address
them in future videos